over six incredible weeks this colossal
complex of snow and ice has risen from
the banks of the Turner River in far
northern Sweden as it has each year for
the last decade and a half it is without
doubt a frozen wonder of the world
thousands of tons of snow and ice
designed built and sculpted by an
international team
it's the biggest igloo on the planet the
giant ice chandelier hanging in the main
hall is the only feature that remains
the same year after year
everything else is created as a unique
piece just for this year's Ice Hotel
fiber optic and LED lighting transformed
each room into a Fantasyland
it's d-day in Lapland and the first
guests check into one of the most
amazing hotels on the planet it'll only
be open for three months then it will
melt before it does 12,000 guests will
stay here for at least one night tens of
thousands more will visit for a day this
is literally a once-in-a-lifetime
experience
because in just a few months time all
this would have melted to nothing
experience a bar where the drinks don't
come with ice they come on ice and in
ice every glass is made of the same ice
as the hotel
in the nearby ice factory the ice lathes
are working full-time to create
thousands of these one use only ice
glasses in a single season around 800
tons of Turner River ice will be turned
into these glasses nearly a million in
total
they're used then they melt just as
everything here will eventually melt to
its creators the ice hotel is not so
much a building it's an inspiration it's
frozen once a year
shines briefly then returns to nature
from whence it came